montréal tourner la page du baseball
majeur comme le sous-entendent est
tantôt le vice président des expos
depuis le temps qu'elles avaient été
annoncées
eh ben la voilà la fin d'une histoire de
36 ans entre les exploits leurs
partisans les dernières années ont sans
doute laissé un goût amer à plusieurs
mais quand même il restera de bons
souvenirs trente six ans que nous
raconte jean sébastien cloutier le 8
avril 1969
les ex pour battre lille met sa new york
la première équipe canadienne du
baseball majeur et biên et puis quelques
jours plus tard au parc jarry
une autre victoire pour le premier match
local les expos ont désormais sur nos ce
sont nos amis j'étais tellement fier
j'avais dit à tous mes capella dans
l'équipe des braves que claude raymond
deviendra un expo l'époque du parc jarry
c'était lui mais c'était aussi un
artiste homme mike jones & coco laboy
l'équipe passera huit saisons là-bas
plein de hauts et de bas et en 1977 et
le grand déménagement la ligue au stade
olympique
c'est un formidable montée lire un gros
stade ouverture paris match au stade
olympique
l'ambiance kavala et l'ambiance d'un
stade olympique lorsque les expos grogne
et ils gagnent souvent les premières
années les vedettes ne se comptent plus
carter valentine's un seul round rogers
les expos devienne une des meilleures
équipes du baseball en 1981
ils sont à un match d'aller en série
mondiale mais ce coup de circuit
fatidique de les demandes d'aidé dans le
jeu les élimine à l'époque des exposés
des quatre heures l'attirait plus rien
qu'ils ignorent au les yankees de new
york des experts est plus apte à 183 les
exploits de 2.7 millions de biens à
revenir handicap honnête et à montréal
les années passent et les salaires des
joueurs augmente
josh bratman l'actionnaire principal de
l'équipe abandonne le besbas le joueur
le plus utile
jazz rock funk a deux atouts passion
pour le baseball et l'argent pour
financer ce baseball l'arrivée de claude
brochu et odile de propriétaire il y
avait ni hainaut mais sur le terrain les
expos se débrouille bien
il y a eu le match parfait de dennis
martinez
et en 92 felipe alou devient gérant deux
ans plus tard les expos sont la
meilleure équipe du baseball mais une
grève des joueurs vient anéantir le rêve
d'une série mondiale puis c'est le début
de la fin claude brochu vend ses joueurs
vedettes pour sauver des sous pour moi
ça devient évident c'est que les expos
ne peuvent pas survivre au stade
olympique
mais l'appui espérer des gens d'affaires
et du gouvernement ne vient pas et
pendant qu'au stade vladimir guerrero
ont fait vibrer les partisans de moins
en moins nombreux en coulisses
l'américain jeffery lollia devient
actionnaire principal de l'équipe en 99
il abandonne vite le projet d'un stade
se brouille avec les actionnaires
québécois effet un coup d'argent en
vendant l'équipe au baseball majeur
dès lors le départ des expos étaient une
quasi certitude
ne restait plus qu'à leur trouver un
nouveau toit la du s'est éternisée
jean-sébastien cloutier radio-canada
moria